It is over 11.
you have freed me
you can't stop this now
you have lost
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new stranger things season 4 part 2 trailer
video we don't have that much long to wait
before more episodes are dropping and they've
already explained what's going on with the time
jump between season 4 and season 5. yes there is
a season 5 they've already renewed it season 5
is supposed to be the last season but there is
a spin-off show that they're developing i'll talk
about that later in the video too they dropped a
couple new promos since the season ended so we'll
break it all down there's a bunch of new footage
a bunch of new previews if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
so the brand new footage just shows 11 coming
out of the tank like she's gotten her powers
back like they did at the end of season four part
one the whole idea is that dr brenner said that
she was supposed to come back and come back even
more powerful than number one than the vector
was supposed to be there's a couple trailer
scenes in the original season four trailer
for part one they actually included a bunch of
footage from part two in the part one trailer
you see her hooking out in these tunnels here with
her powers just everything going crazy all around
her in this suit and later after she's exited the
base outside in the desert hulking out blowing up
a whole bunch of stuff i think it's just meant
to be one of those kind of wtf moments where
they show you at the beginning of season four part
two how powerful she's gotten like they told you
she was super powerful but they're gonna show you
too just to hype up this full-blown wizard battle
that they were hyping up between her and vecta or
her number one however you want to think about him
technically it's the same person but i know there
are a lot of questions about exactly what happened
when she pushed him through the gate back in the
late 1970s and who actually created the upside
down like where did this come from why does it
look like hawkins thankfully after the season came
out millie bobby brown the producers talked about
this kind of clarifying some of these details
the other funny thing the duffer brothers the
creators were talking about is how they literally
forgot will's birthday in previous seasons
like the reason why they didn't celebrate it
in a big way in previous seasons sometimes is
because they just flat out forgot like oh yeah
will has a birthday they briefly addressed that
during season four part one and i think they're
gonna turn will into a bigger thing in how they
solve everything during season four part two
because the upside down literally froze on the day
that he disappeared into the upside down but for
those of you asking whether or not will created
the upside down or he has something to do with
his creation i think that's a coincidence because
of why they explained the upside down looking so
much like hawkins that they call it the upside
down like literally looks like a copy of hawkins
but frozen in time on the date that she opened
the mother gate all these different scenes that
they preview are just the different groups on
the show rallying in the different places that
we last saw them in like you see eddie and
steve's group here preparing to fight vegna
then you see max and lucas back inside vechna's
house because that's sort of his locus of power
like that's where he's been staying this whole
time joyce hopper murray and now dimitri ii are
still in russia you see them looking like they're
investigating some russian facility that's left
over from the experiments they did during season
three if you remember vecna was trying to weaken
the barrier between different dimensions and the
russians themselves were trying to open a gate
inside siberia before they came back to hawkins
so all these scenes of him investigating this
facility here with the black cloud squirreling
that's still inside russia inside the facility
where their version of the gate was where they
were trying to open one initially they were
unsuccessful but i think the whole idea is that
what was happening towards the end of season 4
part 1 weakened the barriers so that probably
caused the russian gate to open just a little
bit enough for this to happen then you have the
california group that look like they're trying to
find 11 as she's exiting the base but for those of
you asking what was going on at the end of season
4 part 1 did 11 create the upside down did vecna
create the upside down millie bobby brown in real
life actually confirmed my suspicion that the
upside-down place here this alternate dimension
always existed like this it just recently started
to look more like hawkins according to her it was
always meant to be this alternate dimension and
when you first see her push number one into this
area it was always meant to look like this just
this red void-like place full of a lot of energy
but not a lot of land masses so this is what it
looked like in the late 1970s she pushes number
one in there and then eventually it starts to
look like the upside down that you remember
from season one so a lot of you asking why did it
start looking like hawkins who did that did will
have something to do with that or did 11 have
something to do with that because it literally
froze on the date that she opened the mother
gate the date that will disappeared the way they
clarified this is that technically it's actually
11 who's to blame for the upside down looking so
much like hawkins but only in an indirect way
so what happened here is that back in the late
1970s the first time she pushed number one into
the upside down it just kept looking like this
like he may have used some of his mental powers
to form his house and some of the aspects of it
but for the most part like this vast area here
this alternate dimension just looked like this
what happened later though in the timeline when
she opened the mother gate in the early 1980s
is that both of the alternate dimensions like
the normal dimension that they come from in the
alternate dimension of the upside down started
to bleed together like they started to literally
overlap and the point of overlap is where hawkins
is and that's why hawkins started to look like the
upside down that you remember is just because
it literally started to overlap with the actual
hawkins in what's happening heading into season
four part two obviously season five is that
both of the dimensions are beginning to overlap
more and more and more and bleed into each other
obviously now more literally because the gaze are
starting to open in a bigger way so technically
11 is the reason why the upside down started
to look like hawkins but not because she was
trying to make it look like hawkins just because
when she opened the mother gate it caused the
dimensions to overlap the other really cool thing
is that they didn't originally call this alternate
dimension the upside down that was more of like a
pop culture thing that the fans created that they
made canon after the fact initially when they were
developing the series they called it the nether so
it wasn't always supposed to look like the upside
down like i said it's because 11 opened the mother
gate later on and i think the explanation for why
it's frozen at the date that she opened the mother
gate is just because of the way it overlapped with
hawkins on that date it's not so much because of
something that will did but will does seem like
he has a special connection with the mind flayer
so the next big question everyone's asking is
who is the ultimate big boss of this show like
who is gonna be the villain of season five if it
seems like they're hyping up eleven versus number
one during season four part two this gets back
to what dusty said during season four part one
during an episode he literally says the mind
flayer exists like a level above number one
wait wait wait what do we know that wants to
take over the world the mind players so if the
demogorgon was just his foot soldier feckness his
five-star general but because they made the mind
flair the villain of previous seasons controlling
other things what they might wind up doing is
say the mind player was trying to control
what vecna was doing like kind of twist him
against hawkins and use him the same way that he
wants to use eleven's power to open the gates more
fully and overlap the dimensions permanently
so that he can absorb the regular dimension
because they kind of hiked that up in previous
seasons like the whole idea is that the mind
flare basically wants to eat other dimensions and
make them part of his own upside down dimension
and if you're not a big dungeons and dragons
fan they actually did play some funny dungeons
and dragons in real life to promote the season
but within the canon of dungeons and dragons
when you talk about the different villains that
they make for the different seasons vechna is
like a lich he's not meant to be like the
big bad of dungeons and dragons so that's
why i think that he's not meant to be like the
ultimate big bad of the show and eleven will
wind up blowing through him during season four
part two like they will defeat him in some way
he won't be the ultimate big bad of season five
a lot of you also asking now small detail does
this mean that 11 is kind of like his surrogate
child if number one said that brenner tried to
recreate him using parts of him with these other
children i think the idea is that her mother
was actually already pregnant with her when she
entered the mk ultra experiments and he started
experimenting with her using the biological parts
of vechna that he'd extracted from him so he's
more metaphorically the father of what eventually
11 became but he's not like her biological father
secretly or anything like that like when he's
telling her all these things he's trying to mess
with her head saying that i'm way better than you
are but brenner revealed that ultimately because
of what they're doing she's supposed to be way
more powerful than him which i think is just a big
hap tip to whatever the ending is gonna wind up
being like she will eventually defeat number one
for those of you asking what happened to the other
children who survived because they had the whole
thing with number eight with kali who just kind of
took off into the ether in previous seasons she's
still alive out there somewhere what they'll
probably do is they'll probably try to bring
kali number eight whoever else survived from
the program if there's anybody else beyond her
back during season five i'm not expecting to see
her during season four part two there are a couple
scenes that we see of them inside the upside
down like you see eddie playing heavy metal music
inside the upside down but on the trailer like
on the other side of the gate inside his trailer
it looks like they're using that to just try and
confound the demo bats this sort of ties in with
the whole kate bush thing running up that hill
the idea that music somehow helps them beat what
vecna number one is doing mostly by interrupting
the psychic signal that he's using to control
people but all the other footage that you see
in the trailer for season four part two is them
just in different parts of the real world and
inside the upside down trying to fight the forces
of fagno like i said they're just meant to show
you the two different universes slowly bleeding
into each other slowly overlapping if there's any
big questions that you have that i didn't address
during the video or big easter eggs that i didn't
talk about just write them below in the comments
i will do more videos for the final episodes
because there's only two final episodes there's
not going to be that much stuff everyone click
here to learn about the brand new game of thrones
jon snow sequel series that hbo is making and
click here for my first look at the avatar the
last airbender movie trilogy that they're making
they finally released the first look at that
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!